Forza horizon 2 was my favorite game of
2014 so it would make sense that I would
be super stoked to see an announcement
442 motorsports six but I wasn't it was
strange I had this feeling like I had to
hand over my keys for joyriding too much
for having too much fun and now it's
time to go back to the confines of the
safe and sterile track where I can no
longer taint the 2014 vintage Barolo
wines with rubber and other car [ __ ]
Verizon do beautifully melds the
wonderfully entertaining fort sac our
roster and driving dynamics with an open
world full of race courses and
activities just all designed to maximize
absurd fun in traditional terms it would
be called Arkady but what it really is
is a fantasy simulator why yes let's
race Lambos around the Italian
countryside and scenic coastal roads and
no let's not worry about the carnage
because doing it it sounds simple yet I
can't emphasize enough how great this
ends up being for a guy who spends loads
of money and time chasing very real
experiences every time I play this game
even though I'm just laying on the couch
with my cat sleeping on me I feel like
I've done something very very real and
yet professor scratch remains
undisturbed it's such an addicting thing
too it's something I certainly got out
of the fort to motorsport games but
unleashing these cars and their detailed
handling on the open world of horizon 2
it's just something else entirely
something better and inevitably it's
diluted how gripped i am with most other
video games across all genres but i
still chase it and it would make sense
that other drive engines was satisfied
so how did some of last year's racers do
when drag club hits your eyes it's
impressive the cars and environments are
exquisitely detailed which keeps you
focused on the driving but eventually
the limited car selection modest
handling and AI that's just stuck in the
race line will wear down any enjoyment
you're experiencing it's not an
open-world racer but that tracks aren't
circuits they are however not designed
to maximize the pure
real of just driving they don't have a
good flow or any highly exhilarating oh
my gosh I am the greatest moments built
in them having little mini challenges
mid-race is a fun distraction that game
is missing something which makes other
driving games transcend to more than
just as parts it's a bit soulless also
the drifting is so hard and frustrating
it just makes no sense especially since
the rest of the driving is actually
pretty forgivable what about the crew it
has such an awe-inspiring world to drive
through the interpretation of the United
States in that game is endearing and
it's really fun to explore it's just a
shame you have to do it in such yawn
inspiring cars it's a campaign focus
game with an MMO in there somewhere if
you look hard enough there are events
and races that put you into phone cars
but the race layouts just are inherently
fun and don't flow well the cars all
handle in such a way to that no you are
playing a game rather than driving the
car which is so emphasised by the nitro
boost you're constantly using the raid
missions and extreme races are pretty
outrageous and deserve a tip of the hat
but they just can't hold a candle to the
cross country stuff in horizon 2 for
pure enjoyment which brings me to the
storm island DLC storm island felt like
a bit of an answer to the crew style of
raid missions the new map cars upgrades
and races are so extremely entertaining
than I find myself falling in love with
ports of horizon to all over again it's
a little expensive for what you get but
you know going back to my point about
chasing experiences it's actually
supremely cost-effective sure the dirt
tracks an open-field running are just
not as accurately simulated as maybe say
spin tires but I don't walk away from
spin tires with an elevated heart rate
and a huge grin on my dumb face grid
Autosport offered a really nice circuit
racing package especially for PC gamers
looking for their fix but it has that
same problem I'm having with the thought
of going back to forza motorsport I'm
just not ready to be confined by the
tyranny of the track man in my ideal
world Forza horizon 2 would just
constantly be updated with content I
would probably never go back to a
circuit rates again although Who am I
kidding I'm at least gonna see what
ports of motorsport 6 is like however
with really impressive looking offerings
from the likes of assetto corsa and
project cars enticing return to the more
structured sim style racer forts of
motorsports 6 is going to have to work
extremely hard to get drivers to be
excited for track day again